CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell was deputy
director and acting director of the CIA
good morning Michael
good morning Anthony the Defense
Department Michael is saying we're not
seeking conflict with Iran so what
message are we sending by sending a
thousand troops to the Middle East
Anthony I think we're sending the
message that we're gonna defend our
interests and I actually think this step
is prudent as David Martin told us
earlier in the program
the job of these additional forces is
going to be increased surveillance
watching the Iranians and it's going to
be to defend US forces and US military
bases so I think it makes sense from
both a messege perspective and a defense
of our forces perspective
Michael this comes as Iran is increasing
its nuclear enrichment one US official
called this nuclear blackmail is that
how you see it so this is a step by the
Iranians to put additional pressure on
the international community to push us
to stop our maximum pressure campaign
that's what they tried to do last week
with the attack on the ships that's what
they're trying to do now by taking one
step away from the nuclear agreement
they they are under severe pressure from
sanctions they want that to stop and
this is the course that they've chosen I
think it's really important to note
Adriana that they are still a long way
even if they break this threshold for
low enriched uranium they're a long way
away from a nuclear weapon so we are not
on the verge of a nuclear crisis here
that would be at least a year away
Michael what do you think of the
intelligence released by the u.s.
allegedly showing Iran placing or at
least removing a mine on the whole of
one of these tankers does that support
Mike Pompeo and president Trump's
position that Iran is definitely behind
these attacks Tony I think so
I was persuaded by the high-resolution
photographs I was persuaded by the
timeline that the administration
released yesterday I was persuaded last
Thursday by the Secretary of State's
strong statement and most importantly I
was persuaded on Sunday on Face the
Nation when Adam Schiff the ranking
Democrat of the House Intelligence
Committee told Margaret Brennan
that the evidence that the Iranians are
behind this is strong and Adam is is no
fan of the administration so the fact
that he has seen the intelligence and
says it's strong is convincing to me
Michael when you're talking about this
area of the world grainy photos
allegedly showing something a lot of
people their mind is cast back to 2002
2003 and the run-up to Iraq are our
allies punishing us today for mistakes
apparently made way back then so I think
there are three issues Tony one is the
Iraq issue right it's going to take a
long time before that gets out of
people's memory the the second issue is
that this administration let's face it
says falsehoods every day particularly
out of the White House and that has
undermined our credibility so we have to
overcome that but perhaps most important
are the other nations of the world
including our allies and partners
actually blame us for the situation that
we're in today they blame us for pulling
out of the nuclear deal and creating
this crisis so when you put all three of
those together that's why they're
responding the way they are to what
happened last week so so how close
Michael do you think we are actually do
a conflict with Iran here so I believe
that neither country at this point wants
war Iran doesn't want it
president Trump doesn't want it the
United States doesn't want it I think
that could change if they get close to a
nuclear weapon but as I said earlier
that's a year away I think the risk of
conflict right now would be by
miscalculation if the Iranians
miscalculate and were to attack a US
military base or a US Embassy and
actually kill Americans I think we'd be
in a different place or if the Saudis or
the Emiratis were to respond and attack
Iran I think we'd be in a different
place so miscalculation could bring us
to conflict alright Michael Morell for
us Michael thank you very much